welcome to the civilian plane
Grandmaster shade from Poland Poland
right and this is something no no name
sloth sloth defense that's a sense
laughs oh let's see what should I do
okay let's play three probably knows it
about ten times better than I do but but
anyway
ok be both them centralized pieces try
to improve the position yeah the pawn
breaks re4 and d5 for both sides and he
could also try a c5 Phoenix ok is going
for c5 I was setting up this rookie one
Bishop f1 in case of c-5 so that i can
now fianchetto the Bishop Bishop seem he
wants to use them the C file
if I take it he can probably take with
the rock here but I need to I need to
clarify things here on the c forum we
take it with a rock i'm playing a queen
d3 my idea not nice but I need to I need
to get rid of the sea file pressure
I was thinking maybe maybe had something
pétain okay this night night gee forms
one issue let's maybe here to prevent
that and also have to look at the CH
square
yeah fairly complicated position how to
how to evaluate for me with limited time
so many complications in the center
confirm now you can think of just
playing a bishop to see aid so not too
ridiculous Mary I don't really want to
exchange
but maybe wish that I could take a look
takes 94 because these six are saying
okay I this I didn't really think about
might be five however was an idea it's
not to answer maybe that one yeah
attending whoops you were CMC one and
maybe Bishop defo v6 as a weakness
and now if he tries bishop c8 not saying
that it's great anyway I could maybe
change resting interesting I don't
understand that really okay i take i
mean i understand that he's opening the
long diagonal but and I don't add let's
not let's not lose all time over this
hard to imagine that I should not grab
it so let's grab it okay Bishop to rook
age 50 kita drop back here yeah Knight
g4 but I've got night f4 also
night f-for my when he would need to
take this also be six hanging now this
is in fact quite strong
Bishop c7 I can just take d8 with the
Queen winning winning on the spot and
rube d7 maybe neither form ok I have to
hang some but talk to you soon okay so
turn playing that even night afore I
still like the smooth still have to hang
some
okay that's protected I see if I go
night f 4 p-6 whatever what's hanging
okay I'd still fairly fairly solid is
dead okay
hmm
this is poo it gets dangerous and 40
seconds Sam
maybe just a five man it's okay
impossible to calculate he spends lots
of time though if I've I have the check
a very big check man I'm very slow in
this game just lucky that not losing
already maybe I am I mean
check
check check check
okay what's this value say flack for
fits on time yeah it's fairly safe also
because he lost some time but it's just
a piece now right yeah it's just a piece
who was I was very dangerous around here
thought okay well I'm just winning but
that's not the case we gave one probably
necessary him computer wants to do that
why isn't as possible while computer
chess 27 and wins yeah okay pretty
impossible I was just thinking all right
I don't give away my bishop here then
then idea for is really killing this is
a check okay yellow not not in the Blitz
game this was normal computer says I'm
winning but and now it Oh Bishop e3 is
the best move yeah but it was at least
for the computer check says it's the
best move it super-complicated it wants
to go Bishop see ATM the main thing is
that this is answered will check with
Queen check which I didn't really see
beforehand but is this good takes check
yeah this is this is winning Queen f5
it's the computer solution was even more
convincing but it's it's just a piece
basically wow very complicated game
thanks for watching